quelquefois je pleure et je rage on ne
peut pas toujours être sage
à
j'ai peur de la nuit j'ai pas de
charpente utg pas les cheveux crêpés
j'ai pas la dernière coupe pas de condos
dans la aussi des alouettes chaque mot
chat qui dort il veut toujours là c'est
j'ai pas de petit atout caché sur la
fesse gauche j'ai pas la non au sein
pour sortir quelque chose
j'ai pâture d'héroïne mais j'aime bien
la bière je suis pas toujours in mais
qu'est ce que ça peut faire j'ai pas la
faire à bague comme dans le film diva il
m'a donné une bague et de mal et c'est
là je ne le suis toujours par an chez
sur internet patch et une bonne vision
des jeux plus monsieur n'est quelques
quoi tu peur et je rage on ne peut pas
toujours être sage comme une image
quelquefois je pleurais je rage en ne
peut pas toujours être ça
le plus besoin d'aller dans le montagnes
russes j'aime bien aller nager et plus
dans péribus j'avais pas 100% quand
j'allais à l'école tueur me suis perdu
dans mon imagination je veux bien là car
les avions qui décollent je me sens très
bien de la civilisation
quelquefois je pleure
l'orage on ne peut pas toujours être
sage
pourquoi je pleurais je rage en ne peut
pas toujours être ça
j'ai pas lu jean paul sartre et j'ai pas
les mains sales j'ai pas du rambo 4 et
j'en suis pas plus mal j'ai pas perdre
en moi sinon j'ai attaqué j'ai un petit
désespoir qui vient de visiter j'ai plus
de moustiquaires manche à la déchirer
j'ai pas besoin de faire semblant pour
exister
pourquoi je pleure je rage on ne peut
pas toujours être sage
quelquefois je pleure
rage entre eux peut pas toujours à tout
âge
on
je rêve pas d'avoir châteaux en espagne
je connais personne là bas je préfère la
bretagne je suis papa makhoul
bouddhistes ou communistes je suis pas
contre pour mais j'aime bien mon
fleurissent je suis pas une poupée qui
fait non non non non je ne mets plus des
caps et alors là attention
pourquoi je pleure réchauffera ne peut
pas toujours être sage
une fois je pleurais jour agents ne peut
pas toujours être tâche
quelquefois je pleurais je rage on ne
peut pas toujours être
comme une h